2 Chainz was the guy who debated Nancy
Grace about weed remember that yeah wait
is gonna kill ya he outlasted her yeah
that didn't work
I mean it's hilarious now and see how
many states have legalized it and in
full disclosure Ron and I smoked
marijuana with young Jamie before this
podcast as I do so many others it's
finally the stigma slowly being removed
slowly
dude I was a drug addict in the 90s when
I started my first first welcome weed I
guess it was not even the 90s it was
like was a night maybe 98 or 99
somewhere around that it's when I
started smoking weed and you were a drug
addict you were drug addict to a
marijuana user what's wrong with you man
get your shit together I'm like man you
guys don't get it there's 2 Chainz there
he is a Nancy Grace they put the stuff
on the screen when it was going on how
many marijuanas does it take to overdose
fucking amazing quote did she really say
that no no it's a twitter user they put
we're tweeting whatever hashtag pot to
blame oh my god oh that twitter user Oh
Skyler
Tyler 2015 Oh Tyler 2015 do that but is
2015 the day of the tweet must be not as
practiced in as an account I don't know
what happened it's a weird time Dhokla
there's a space in there said I don't
know well yeah I think 2015 well weather
I don't know I don't know whoever's
whoever that is congratulations made me
laugh my ass off yeah that's funny
oh yeah that's why I was a ridiculous
lady you know she's she obviously wasn't
that healthy you know she wasn't like a
very fit health conscious person just
worrying about weed she's just a crazy
person she was like Paula Deen but she
couldn't cook food marijuana gonna kill
you Ron Funches people still like that
there's a lot of people like that in the
middle of the country in another country
sometimes it's still like you know
there's a lot of stigma have been
racially you know depends they get the
the soccer weed moms and everybody's
like oh that's cool and then you still
get that like I did a podcast the other
day and the first comments were like
either yours too stoned you're not doing
it like no I just did a bad job you know
right I could have just done a bad job
it didn't have anything to do with me
being stone yeah like they know that if
you were sober the podcast would have
been way better yeah you were sober man
you would have been so weird that's true
it's all true I just have to go to this
place the Englewood Wellness Center so
it was kind of in a hood area um little
bit sketchy and then while we're going
there like within a year or two later
the guy who ran it got shot and robbed
there it's like that's how dangerous
weed was cuz yet do it all in cash they
wouldn't let banks use checks they
wouldn't I wouldn't accept checks and
credit cards so everything was weird
even though it was medical and it was
legal you had to get it through
nefarious ways and then slowly but
surely the stigma started to erase yeah
now you can just go to a store on
Melrose yes like adults
like what how do you feel you're a wise
man
how do you feel I should have qualified
that I'm setting you up what do you
think about making all drugs legal do
you think that that would ever happen
and given what we know about prohibition
sounds like an interview mmm given what
we know about prohibition like how bad
it was for alcohol and how it popped up
the organized crime and I mean caused a
lot of problems do you think it would be
a wise thing to make all drugs legal
that's a tough question for me I think
that's um I think you have to start I
guess that's really trying to give
people a lot of credit about their
intelligence and their decision-making
right and that's when you're trying to
lead towards that the that the
individual is very intelligent and they
they're going to make their decision no
matter what and that if I put any stigma
to it just like you know like
you know prostitution things like that
you're just adding extra jail time extra
obstacles extra life-threatening
situations and you're also penalizing
people for their own life choices
instead of propping up organized crime
mm-hmm or as well as where they're
propping up organized crime but if
you've seen the effects of drug
addiction which I've had on occasion you
use hard to go like yeah this should be
okay you know I'd 100% agree so it's
it's not that clean no I don't think
that's wise yeah that would be my
answers I don't think it's that clean I
think that it is a case-by-case basis
will do I think marijuana should be
legal I have absolutely do I think that
you shouldn't necessarily legalize
heroin no I don't think so
I don't think so either um but I think
that I think there's a real problem with
infantilizing adults the the real
problem is like if you are 25 years old
or older and you decide you want to try
cocaine who's who's why can they say you
can't do that
why says who says ooh why is that why
why if you catch me with that can you
put me in a jail it grows from the
ground it's a plant they take that plant
they process it they turn into cocaine
they still use it legally for lidocaine
and medical-grade cocaine they still use
it for the flavor of coca-cola they
still use the leaves they still use the
plant like who says I don't even do coke
but who the fuck do you think is making
money selling coke because there's a lot
of coke it's one thing that's completely
no there's no other industry in Miami
and there's so much money there did you
see cocaine Cowboys mmm no oh dude Billy
Corbin the guy who directed it was on
the podcast yesterday he's uh he's
fantastic and he's got this new
documentary called screwball it's about
Alex Hernandez and steroids and baseball
and all this crazy shit he gets oh right
Rodriguez who's Alex Hernandez this is a
different one a rod how does a guy know
that's Aaron there's
in New England's Atrus goddamn we'd fuck
my head up that is the guy from the
Patriots no there's air in her name okay
that's where I fucked it up my apologies
Alex Alex Rodriguez and uh anyway this
this guy made a documentary called
cocaine cowboys and it's all about how
crazy during the big cocaine days Miami
was and how one year the entire
graduating class of the sheriff's
Academy the police academy whatever it
was they either were murdered or they
were arrested for corruption the whole
everyone the entire class like the
entire graduating year like every it was
wild west chaos and there was all these
pilots bringing in millions of dollars
worth of coke and they had bags of money
buried in their backyard it's fucking
crazy and it's great man it's great it's
a two-part series there's two parts to
it - do you ever - Virgin Black Mafia
family you ever you ever watch any
documentaries about them no that makes
me always interested what did they do
they were a cocaine outlet in the early
2000s out of Atlanta and they transit at
one point they were running like most of
the south-southeast headed by the
student named big Meech and then they
decided like we should legalize and get
into a rap but they had never done
anything like that before and they were
very blatant about it so all of a sudden
these people who were came out of
nowhere we're just all on like every
magazine that they have this thing where
they're interviewed interviewing police
officers and they had this big billboard
when you would landed Atlanta that would
go that would just say BMF we own the
world and they were just out there and
they would throw these big parties with
Tigers and stuff
and they only had one recording artist
so it was just like they weren't good at
pretending not to be drug dealers it so
it's very interesting to me